daddy's home - in theaters near you on
November 10th starring in Parkton to my
right great choice of song about walking
on water because he is here dressed
head-to-toe full-on with the beard and
in the robe and everything in the
sandals
Will Ferrell dressed as go ahead say
tell the radio audience who you're
dressed as today Jesus
courtesy of spirit costumes made in
China man it's adult and if you if you
can focus into the barber yes
one size fits most one size fits most so
they're not really committing are they
know you're not really convinced size
fits most how does it fit you it looks
like it fit really good yeah pretty good
yeah pretty good but uh yeah I am and
you've got a Dodger cap on as well so I
want to support my Dodgers I looked at
the calendar it didn't dawn on me they
until yesterday yeah that today is the
30th it is that I thought got a beard a
beard really puts me out of breath
there's only this much yeah just some
pre eyes right um but boy Jesus does
love his omega-3s look how shiny anyway
my point is my kids we have a rule in
the Ferrill household the boys get to
pick out my halloween costume every year
and have to wear it no matter what okay
so they had picked out Jesus I thought
day before Halloween I gotta wear it for
rich on a show thank you
yeah well thanks hildren Thank You
children for me courtesy of axel Magnus
and Mattias okay they saw to be fun
why did they I don't know there's no
real ass here I was a poop emoji one
year I was just a heavyset guy okay I
think I was Where's Waldo
no year yeah it there's no rhyme or
reason okay and then I just you know I'm
very rarely I pay attention to another
person sandals but I noticed that your
sandals have the your initials on yes W
and W F okay though
where'd you get those are those
specifically made for you they were
specifically made for me
no I actually went to an outlet mall and
had a WF I was up in Camarillo are those
Fred Willard I'm just wearing my friends
different they're in the 30% off bin and
so I lucked out interesting and then
again I it just really dress up for the
Halloween do you dress up I am gonna
dress up tomorrow yeah my plan is my
children didn't choose this but I'm
gonna go as fought will Larry David
fought whoa
yes if you've seen his getup in his okay
first couple of episodes after season
that's great yeah that's what I'm sure
when it's Jim Harbaugh I've got the
khakis and they're perfect and that cap
and they put on cleats and khakis that's
walking people and intensely talking to
them and pointing up and benched a few
people which is really strange when
you're when you're triggered right right
people like you know what gives it's
just the way I kind of you know yeah
Will Ferrell here on the Rich Eisen show
as Jesus it's gonna be difficult on
occasion to have a conversation you know
through the through the beard here's
already I'm already thinking to tomorrow
in the evening Halloween evening okay I
am blazing hot I'm given I think the
over-under on the beard and the Hat is
maybe and the wig is is maybe 15 minutes
I mean it'll be nighttime you should
wear that to the game tomorrow god I
should I should throw out the first
pitch
Dodgers if you're listening Jesus is
ready to go first pitch well that would
definitely get the Astros off their game
a little they probably have Sandy Koufax
lined up or something just like sandy
goes out maybe it's a one-two combo
sandy and Jesus together Wells Jesus
alrighty I think it depends on the day
yeah it's whatever he wants but this
Jesus is a righty this this Jesus could
be a lame lefty or a pretty proficient
righty yeah yeah
I'd imagine well didn't have you done
the first pit if you were going first
fish have you did you go from the mound
of course you have to
for them come on stupid quietly I were
her I practiced I did did you bounce it
or I didn't what I did was I didn't you
didn't fit fitty Senate card right by
the way that's a great that's amazing
verb did you meet a few fit he says an
amazing clip though oh gosh she's at the
Mets well that is why it is a
frightening thing because if you dirt it
fit if you fit he sent it fit he said if
you launch it it's there forever your
children see it so what I did was as I
went from the mound yeah and what what I
did was I threw it and the ball broke
into the right-handed hitters batter's
box so a lefty might have swung over the
no play my off-speed I would have hit a
right-handed hitter and look Oh guard it
okay crazy thing is who caught it it was
at the time somebody who really wasn't
very prominent on the on the dog Kenley
Jansen caught is your catcher he was
because he was a converted former
catcher yeah so I'm taking credit for
his ascension I love that you went
shades you went cool-guy shades I did
yeah well you know Ella Forney guy I
hold a sudden your California I had will
I had to hide the abject fear one of the
crazier ones I did was at Fenway and I
somehow convinced them to let me where
1975 Boston Red Sox you know cool
uniform like the old carton fish Louie
Tiant Oh Louie T I ran I ran from the
bullpen as they announced me to right
field all the way home which was amazing
cuz the crowd it was this low kind of
roar as I ran and they finally noticed
was it but totally winded by the time I
got to yeah
and so what'd you do did you I got you
out it over Josh Beckett Josh Beckett
caught me okay that's good so I yeah but
you and you've played you played nine
positions in one day right didn't you do
that it's great training I did ten
counting th is that so good I bet you
know there you are in the nays and then
a Mariners so what were you more winded
then or right now just sadly didn't
someone did it this year did they I
think they did a copy and the announcer
mentioned the same as will fair
who is not a professional baseball
player but somehow I get the same credit
look at that man oh my gosh yeah you try
to climb yeah I try to find the wall too
far though right you're okay
Will Ferrel here in the Rich Eisen show
did you watch last night's game five I I
was at Hamilton dressed as Jesus no I
was at Hamilton it was a belated
birthday gift to my father okay he'd
never seen her it's finally out here in
Los Angeles and so we took a whole gang
of people and and what was fascinating
was so three hours of Hamilton yes and
at the end people immediately checking
their phones and at that point it was 12
11 so you didn't miss again and then you
started hearing people going you heard
someone like four sections over they
tied it up what they tied it up 12 12
oh just 12 12 and it's spread light and
we ran to the car and we listened on the
radio only to hear them lose yeah so I
guess in a way yeah would you have
preferred it that way or would you have
wanted to sit there and live and die in
a way to not have to go through the
agony I mean yeah we were enjoying
ourselves we're having a wonderful
family experience are you saying would I
rather trade in city but yeah so I feel
like I sort of watched it mmm but I
really didn't okay yeah they could have
had the guy who played Lafayette like
wrapped up date you know Kershaw now
they bleed because it's now four four
right I've just have done that by the
way look at me riffing like now note to
the producers at the Pantages Theatre or
tomorrow night let's maybe incorporate
real real time scoring notice to
lin-manuel Scully
think about it just think about it just
think about it sorry if you had to right
now guess the temperature that you are
not underneath that costume right now
what would that be will I'm gonna go
well today's coolers right there's not
we had that heatwave last week we all
God right you that was crazy thank God
it's gonna be 67 degrees yellowy night
yes I've checked the weather I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say I'm definitely pitting
out I'm gonna say 85 degrees right now
but your lights are pretty cool here
they're not too bright you know we're
try to keep the temperature so not cool
for when people show up it's more right
and heat right in here it's like a
Amazon rainforest right underneath the
beard in the chin the yeah the neck and
chin area are moist how does Justin
Turner do it I don't know I don't know
right by the way when you just shook
your head there was quite it's quite a
movement right how does Justin Turner do
that I could not imagine how the
grooming belongs you because you keep it
you keep your beard nicely trimmed I
don't know this have you ever let it
really go it gets like a cough drop
brother gets it starts to itch it feels
crazy so I don't know how Justin term a
bee get past that point
he's desensitized but you got to watch
food you got to watch all that stuff oh
yeah let's take a 60-second break when
we come back we'll talk about daddy's
home - okay and more with Will Ferrell
layer on the Rich Eisen
[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show we
celebrated our third anniversary just
earlier this month I know we have a new
record here first of all not only as
Will Ferrell is sitting to my right here
dressed as Jesus are you the first
person to come dressed fully head-to-toe
as Jesus you are the first guest we've
ever had in the commercial break have
there upper or upper cheeks basically
patted down for sweat we've never had
that before
a pratikriya chopper cheek region the
upper cheek region pat down that's
pretty yeah yeah TSA should that should
be expert that what clearly you were a
man who commits when given the
opportunity what is the one thing that
you were asked in your television or
movie career to commit to that you
yourself will ferrell said you know what
i that one I can't even do I don't know
if it has I I mean I that was kind of
one of my rules on when I started on SNL
as I went to all the writers and I said
I will do anything to get on camera and
we yeah it just became one at one of my
buddy Adam McKay used to love to just
write me into sketches at some point
during the sketch you would say and then
will is shirtless and I don't I mean I'm
an average I'm not you know I'm an
average shape borderline unfit mmm-hmm
sometimes more fit than other times but
I'm not I wouldn't say I'm grotesque
looking but I think it was it was it was
freeing for the audience to see someone
who looks like the guy next door willing
to just take his shirt off at a moment
and just go daddy whities and whatever
whatever tighty whities so you've never
said you know what I just really in fact
if anything I would get in trouble there
I got in trouble with the NBC censor
once yeah how so
we did a sketch right after 9/11 we're
in enough time had passed to where we
thought we could start to to be a little
more to be funnier and it sensitivity
had died down and so we
get a sketch about an office where
everyone's wearing patriotic stuff red
white and blue flag tie a panel Appel
and I came in with red white and blue
dolphin shorts and the point was they
were like well that's not appropriate
I'm like why why are my dolphin shorts
any different from your American flag
tie well when we did the live show I cuz
it SNL you do a dress rehearsal show and
yes do the live show let's just say for
the live show I tucked the dolphins up a
little higher than they should have been
and the sensor really got mad at me
afterwards because it was live TV yeah
so it was asking for forgiveness rather
than permission so I was there I was
sticking my rear end into Rachel Dratch
his face and things like that
yeah so no I would say I don't know if I
have one a moment where I said no I
can't do it well I'll tell you man this
is a heck of a commitment you're yakking
here today and I greatly appreciate that
before we get to daddy's home - well I
don't know if you caught this because
there are many anchorman moments in my
life where I will read anything off the
prompter sometimes and I'm like damn it
that's a Ron Burgundy moment
did you catch dick Stockton's reading a
promo at the end of a half of the game
okay let's play this this happened dick
Starr the great dick is great diksa yes
of course had shared a total Ron
Burgundy venerable dick stock play this
place for a Will Ferrell of the rookie
cam Robinson and that's a critical
penalty well coming up on the VESA
halftime report
Kurt Terry Howie Michael and Tony look
on graphic for the final two bullet
points final bullet points least San
Diego wasn't told to do something yeah
exactly at least it wasn't something
[Music]
something very naughty yeah yeah
happened yeah Wow yep even to the best
of him Ron having Ron and happened to
dick Stockton's right there and did you
have you know have you heard the story
as well I'd love to get your take on
this and the poor the poor sideline
reporter on that first Monday night
folks Sergio
yeah which wasn't he wasn't reading but
he just had a moment like that that was
me in my first broadcasting class at USC
yeah we had a whole television
production class where I literally
couldn't get the words out and even
though I'd rehearsed it and when the
moment came horrible you had a Sergio
dick Oh big time yeah is there video of
that no of course not no I'll be great
it would be but I don't know yeah is
that a moment where you thought maybe
this is not right for me uh oh yeah yeah
no I I mean I just got the teacher was
like what what happened I'm like I don't
know I can't tell you I don't know it's
harder than it looks
I just said it's harder than it looks
this is hard back to you in the booth I
tell all the analysts on NFL Network all
of them when they come off the field and
I'm gonna blog broadcast with them
you're the safe word for you yeah is
back to you rich Wow yeah because it's
so we had once upon a time I gave that
I'll tell you the story anyone if you
ever got anyone who's just right away
just said back to you right right out of
the gate this is what happened it came
close okay the angle is so real try to
so we're doing it Pro Bowl broadcast
Maurice jones-drew for the Jaguars is
our correspondent for the NFC practice
pays off for the AFC where they're in
Fort Lauderdale Florida it's me Deion
Sanders and Michael Irvin on the main
set and we send Maurice jones-drew to do
interviews into the NFC probe oka and we
tell him beforehand any problems Maurice
just just scream back to you Rick kick
it back to him he goes up to Frank Gore
then of the San Francisco failures and
they're interviewing each other and yes
Frank what it's like to be back in South
Florida because he's from Miami and he
starts to talk about how they should all
hang out later on in the script club and
they Dion and Irv started screaming just
what they're trying to tell me something
yeah writes back to you and then one
other thing I want to get your take on
did you have you seen Jerry Rice what
he's doing
these days he is I don't know if I have
he's crashing weddings for for what
reason just to I don't know there's
there's pictures of him is there some
serious oh yeah they're just he's
showing me weddings but is he making
money off of it I don't for just Rahman
is he just now there's a country club up
there laughter yeah he just meanders
into the reception you know that when we
when we did kicking and screaming the
preeminent pg-13 soccer movie of its
time co-starring with Mike dick dick I
read so we were doing press in Chicago
and we go to dick his restaurant great
place and we're in one of the banquet
rooms and all sudden my clothes well
come with me and I think he's taking me
into the kitchen to meet the chef we
watch through and we walk into another
banquet room where literally the groom
is giving a toast to his it's a wedding
reception and he's just like anyway Judy
you're the love of my life oh my god
Mike Ditka and Will Ferrell Reggie come
over here we'll say if you were I have
to get on the mic and see you actually
crashed a set of yeah we we Kurt with
Mike Ditka and he was LAT he loved it
any I think he just he did he would do
it every time he was and it was it was
actually quite fun oh my god so you've
got daddy's home - daddy's home to you
and Wahlberg back together now yeah I
got Mel Gibson John Lithgow yes now John
is an accomplished
he's an accomplished everything
everything right Tony's Emmys he's got
him all he's got the whole like the
whole right he doesn't have any men's
choices Awards
five-time another guy's choice sorry
guys choice but pardon me
I don't Spike TV thank you got five of
them got five antlers
they're called antlers just in case
you're wondering
in this film John plays your dad he
plays my father Mel plays marks paw
correct and in this film you and John
have an interesting father-son relay
John John and I have a very open
relationship as father and son were open
with our feelings and our emotions and
we express that physically and that
every time we greet each other we kiss
on the lips for a long multiple times
and many times and and that's how we
introduced John into the movie we're
there to pick up our dad's at the
airport and Mel makes this you know
beautiful triumphant studly appearance
as Mark's dad and it kind of informs us
as to why Mark is the way he is this and
then and then lifts go comes down to
some sort of banjo song and we
immediately embrace and kiss multiple
times yeah
now how many takes how many takes well a
lot of takes but also when the camera
wasn't even on us we kept kissing and
just to piss mark off he's like would
you guys stop with the kit what's going
on not only that the day we shot that
were the day but my wife and my three
boys came to watch it I didn't bother to
tell them what they were about to see
how do you do it
it's so embarrassing I'm like well I'm
I'm paid very handsome yeah what a great
lesson to talk about commitment no talk
about professionalism you could talk
about hard work just remember that son
remember that oh my god scene it's
terrific to meet his great audience
hilarious really funny really funny and
uh and to get to see Mel in like a
comedy like this again right he's
fantastic he's he's but it's uh it's
it's definitely worth going to see a
sequel you know when a lot of times
there isn't a reason to this one this
one really came together
there anything from your your
filmography that you'd want to do again
old school you wanna do something
would there be wedding clips episode
maybe just just the Chaz character from
wedding crashers and his own spin-off
there's a there's something in the works
no there isn't but no just put we can we
do it we can do I can do anything I mean
we yeah I could you could join me well
yeah all right mom well I'm all-in
you know Funny or Die word we're doing
something with front of your dime oh
yeah yeah yeah funnier does making
videos for us pitch the pitch app we're
talking about every Friday on yeah
already in the works is the the script
for the levar Ball school of
homeschooling right here on the rich ah
that is fantastic
yes see so you don't even know we
already have a partnership way to go way
to go Funny or Die he's home to in
theaters near you on November 10th
November 10th thanks for showing up here
I got it thanks by the way there is a
shower in the green room should you care
to need it alright you know what I'm
gonna sweat is 1142 Pacific Coast time
yes I can
i can go 24 hours in this show up to my
kids school yep before the Halloween
parade tomorrow are you coaching AYSO in
between them i I'm coaching with my wife
okay we're coaching uh the you nine
anacondas nice yes
that's fearsome its knots fearsome it
was fearsome and having lovely
experiences the parents just what
happened this past week I'm in the
middle of coaching and you know and then
the ball rolls out of bounds a mom picks
up the ball and I think she's about to
throw it back to me but instead yeah
she's holding on to it goes up to her
child on the other team and asks him if
he wants a playdate with his friend
later on and on the coach standing in
the middle of field I now need to
basically say
yeah you please stop interrupting a game
we'll talk yeah yeah that's the beauty
of it that's my but you should show up
like that
I should really freak out the kids well
love having you on it's great to see you
good to see you got it checked out
daddy's home to in theaters near you on
November 10th for more Rich Eisen show
tuned to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Rich Eisen show app